[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon six boys
what is up fam welcome Monday morning it
is a rainy
rainy Monday morning January 9th here in
Calabasas California what is happening
Pete's everybody good everyone doing all
right kids back to school a lot of y'all
driving right now while you're listening
is taking kids back to school back from
the winter break
when a break for parents holidays for
parents is a nightmare
your kid uh is just stuck with you 24 7
huh it's a beast a few weeks so
congrats to all the parents out there
getting the kids back to school shout
out to you man uh shout out to Vegas I'm
fresh off the plane from Vegas Nevada
where is it the Wise Guys Vegas was a
Boomin Vegas had uh a lot going on man
they had freaking oh dude don't give me
story don't even get me started on uh
tiger thick they wouldn't have tiger
thick at the shows because the the
delays like with all the weather back
east and you know we ship out of either
DC or Atlanta it got stuck so we didn't
have tiger thick in Vegas we'll have it
in Tampa that's an easy one that's close
drove me nuts the bottles got to three
cases got delivered today
thank you FedEx I'm not there but uh a
lot was going on Vegas you had the CES
uh convention the big Tech Convention
I'm sure it's all about uh that chat GP
or whatever it is Chad GP and
um then you also had the AVN Awards porn
Awards yup ran to my boy Adam 22 at the
airport him and his girl uh Mrs plug she
uh
she um they won the award for best
podcast and porno
I told him I said uh is there much
competition is there a big kind of
Market he's like no no no no but yeah
they did it man
that's them huh yeah I met his girl too
very pretty very pretty as you know
yeah they call it the plug
oh there it is lives with the award
look at him look at him handsome bastard
and this girl doing the damn thing
yeah he's the man I love Adam and his
girl's super nice they're rushing home
there on the first flight out from Vegas
Sunday morning like I was because
getting back to the kiddos they have a
little daughter
so yeah it goes gotta get back uh Vegas
is great man went to my favorite
restaurant uh fuku Burger shout out to
fuku Burger used to I'll post some pics
there's my son eating a burger a little
thick right there
little thick little thick doing the damn
thing
um yeah Vegas is great man Vegas is dope
tell you what when there's CES and avns
it is
so packed after that I think he said
like 275 000 people come in nuts nuts
all around the all around randar our boy
the schmoe that's this right there the
smoke came to the show and uh yeah he uh
I love this smoke he's that one of the
one of the best dudes in in the sport
man one of the few good guys in the
sport say say the least she's a solid
dude you guys didn't recognize him
without the whole get up no dude dude so
he goes me and uh his girl uh uh
who I love she's getting ready for the
Olympics swim team so she's like swamped
with that so he goes hey man uh uh Yi
gets back today we're gonna come to your
show tonight I'm like cool he's like
come at 7 30. okay cool comes the show
I'm like make sure you come to the green
room so I bring the green room and he's
dressed you know that's the Shmo but
I've seen before I love the dude and
then we get done he's like man I have my
whole get up in my car you wanna do an
interview I'm like between shows like
yeah I might as well let's do it he puts
on things he just zero to 100. touted
dude I mean my brother's watch he's like
holy [ __ ] he saw the interview it was
good yeah he's super fun yeah yeah he's
great man he's a really good dude he's
fun to talk about just um
he's fun there's just so
2023 for MMA has been tough man it's
been the worst
stretch I think I've ever seen in our
sport for so many reasons it's fun to
get with a guy who's been in the
business to talk to him about it talking
about YouTube talking about all sorts of
stuff and he's at all the events and we
were talking and he had a good point
he's like hey man I I don't know if
you've noticed he's like MMA content in
general is kind of like trending low I'm
like yeah it's you know it goes through
depending you know tis the season if
there's a big paper or something like
that if you have big gas it depends on
that stuff he's like I have to give it
all the all the events too man he's like
like the Wayans he's like just barely
anybody there now he goes uh he's like
the UFC's not gonna say it but there's a
reason why they do so much at the Apex
because you know they can control it
there's no crowd there no ticket sales
he's like but a lot of these venues
aren't sold out anymore like what he's
like yeah I mean go all around
interesting you know I think I do think
the bubble has burst as far as MMA goes
in America
unless we get like a bow nickel or they
get another Conor McGregor going here
but currently right now where we're at
where you have you know the Connors
retiring Nate is retired
Connor's not retired about he's kind of
doing his thing you know fighting once
every four years whatever you don't have
like this huge huge draw right now in in
America you know khabib's gone who's Big
here but khabib was giant
internationally
you just get you know it's just we're
going through this weird transition
right now but
could be even mentioned it to you
because that's one of the current events
he's leaving coaching and everything
just to spend time with his family but
could be mentioned like the M.A and his
opinion is starting to drop so yeah
we'll get into that yeah we're gonna
have a theory on that
um yeah it's interesting but shout out
to the Schmo man just great content
absolutely love the guy him and his girl
man just salt of the earth man salty the
earth I was listening to my show uh the
ringer
with Hawaii and Chuck Mendenhall and our
British boy and they started the show
off like oh Brent says he listens go and
chime into the live chat I never do the
live chat I don't know how to do it
sorry guys
um that English guy was like yeah I
think he really thinks I'm a fan I was
like ah man it was a joke oh yeah I
don't think he realized I'm not that
involved in social media where I don't
realize what's a joke and what's not
so when he goes print shop supporter
like you'd have to make a better joke
dude
yeah that's the ringer show right there
oh pizza Carol pizza Carol yeah he said
he was joking
said he's joking I know boy you're also
having a field day with Dana stuff right
he's like he took the high road on that
so he the way he described it was I
didn't hear it do you think you took
your high road yeah I mean he definitely
pointed out some stuff but for the most
part he could have went hard like
hardcore on Dana like one of the things
I think you would understand too that
you would feel is when Dana said like
when Ariel was crying about the whole
making fun of him with Jim Norton uh are
you fun for crying and it was saying
what would your kids yeah and I'm like
dude you anyone who has kids would be
like what the [ __ ]
ah I have no issue with Dana going out
I'm like me and Dana don't have the beef
that Dana and Ariel have like Ariel's in
that business he's a journalist right
like I'm more of an Entertainer so
I'm not a journalist so I don't need
credentials I'm not trying to work at
ESPN I'm not trying to you know work on
UFC now or the The Fight Pass you know
at the time he was with Fox who's the
ESPN well when Dana's also at the same
network he's gonna have a lot of control
and say of what you can and can't do and
Dana really made his life tough man so
there's Dana absolutely like if Dana's
hateless I would you know the guy who
tried blackmail him for the for the you
know the sex videos probably one a
Aerials one B I would assume I'm
probably fourth or fifth and that's an
ego thing I bet I'm not even fourth or
fifth I bet I'm more like nine and ten
on that list but I have no resentment
towards early or Dana in any facet but
when I see Ariel bringing it up
um yeah yeah what'd you think was gonna
happen Dana and then Ariel has a big
voice he's like yo what do you think is
gonna happen man you made that kid's
life miserable it missed out he's
brought this delight miss out on
opportunities money like you mess with
the guy's career man he has kids and
that's the way he feeds his family yeah
dude and you want to mess up like this
what do you think he was going to do you
know
um my thing is on it
[Music]
I don't know how to explain it I'm more
just baffled that's not a bigger story
it's just it's mind-blowing to me I
don't want him to lose his job or get
fired but there should be some
repercussions to hit in your life and my
other thing to that is
if you do that in a public place why
Dana's at a Senior Frogs I have no clue
um I don't know what it was like a
basically a Senior Frogs but if you're
able to I don't drunk any drug you're on
I don't care if you're able to do that
in public around friends and family
you think that's the first time it's
happened
come on yeah if you can do that in
public come on man there's no way that's
the first time so there's obviously some
issues they need to figure out how long
you've known her I don't even [ __ ] she
hit you first you know it's just
it's not the way we work as Society so I
think I'm just more blown away that the
the ESPN will do coverage of a soccer
coach who kicked his wife 30 years ago
when he's 18 and you know whatever
kicked in the leg and that was the
narrative on top the Hamlin story and
then Dana's the face
of the biggest fight organization in the
world and under your umbrella and
there's not a mention of it I'm just
I was just like oh wow and ESPN's you
know pretty far left
let's take a little break from me
chatting your ear off about the
fisticuffs Tampa I will see you January
20th and 21st Tampa Bay improv baby come
get your tickets right now at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com
after that I'm in Springfield Missouri
that is February 3rd through the 5th so
make sure you get your tickets for
Springfield Missouri Naples February
16th through the 18th Bakersfield's one
night only February 23rd so get your
tickets but Tampa you're up that is next
weekend next Friday Saturday only in
Tampa Bay tickets at thickboy.com or
fatkz.com this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by betterhelp that's
right better help and we got you guys
covered with all your mental health
needs when you're at your best you can
do great things but sometimes life gets
you bogged down you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
that you want to you know when you're
not putting your best foot forward well
working with therapist can help you get
closer to be that best version all right
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you life throws you curveballs
2023 is throwing a bunch of curveballs
your way let's knock those out of the
park and turn this bad boy around if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online it's fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist switch therapist
anytime you want for no additional
charge if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com shop schab today
and get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com shop now let's
get back to the program
psych not getting back to the program
one more kids the NFL playoff picture is
locked in and my go-to plays for wild
card action is drafting Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner the NFL
to kick off the road to Super Bowl 57
new customers bet just five dollars and
get 200 and free bets instantly plus all
new and existing customers can get a no
sweat bet each day of the Wild Card
round this freaking weekend just place
any NFL bet on your choice and if it
loses you'll get a free BET back up to
ten dollars action so good why bet NFL
playoffs anywhere else we got you
covered man the Buffalo Bills got a
little something extra on their side be
tough to bet against the bills even if
they're facing the fans I like the bills
all day I like my freaking Chargers over
the Dolphins get it done make some bank
with DraftKings just download the
DraftKings Sports app use code shop show
Schaub show new customers Combat 5 five
dollars on any NFL wild card game and
get 200 in free bets instantly only at
draftking Sportsbook with the code shop
show minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details now let's really get back to the
program it just takes they just to me
they lose credibility
it's like all right because this guy's
on your team and whatever facet you
won't highlight that well that's not
journalism
you guys should report everything
and with Stephen A Smith he's like I
just want first lady you know Dana's a
friend I'm like oh so if you have a
relationship with them no matter what
they do it's all good there's nothing
worse than hitting a woman I mean less
murder outside that to me I I don't have
I don't know anybody who does that you
know so
I guess I'm just more shocked and more
baffled that it hasn't got picked up
more now
Dana was fortunate that the Hamline news
is just all the new cycle and he is on a
sports network but still for whatever 12
hours of the day that they do reporting
you can do a few stories on it you know
so I think the scary thing for people
out there
is that's how powerful Dana is not even
Fox mentioned it his former
his former employer Fox
WME who is essentially his boss now
remember the difference is
you know there will be some bigwigs like
Vince McMahon WWE right his
um
whole you know allegations as far as
paying women all these millions of
dollars and he slept with all these
women pay him under the table to be
silent that's come to to light and he
had to step down but they're a public
traded company they have shareholders so
he had to step down
the only person higher than Dana is Aria
Manuel
at WME they own the UFC right so
um it would have to come from them
silence
in this current climate silence it's
just weird and I you know I'm not a big
fan of the cancel culture and all that
[ __ ]
but for WME who's fired people for way
less and decide to on you know and
especially CA same same people that I'm
with they decide not to work with people
based off just accusations with no
evidence and we have a video I it's just
I shouldn't be surprised and again I
don't want to lose his job but there
should be some repercussions I just
can't believe that he's this powerful I
knew he was powerful
I just had no clue like whoa that's
insane the TMZ thing is like what really
opened my eyes to how powerful he is
well think about it the the story
happened over the weekend right over New
Year's they were on they held on it
until they knew it was coming out then
he came out timzy to apologize before
you saw it
and they decided to do it right around
this big news cycle and they were super
nice to him and gave him so many options
softballs yeah yeah crazy yeah now think
if you're a guy like irohawani and he
has control of your career and he's that
powerful with Mickey Mouse Disney Fox
TMZ imagine the [ __ ] that he did to Air
Hawaii that's where I I kind of
understand with Ariel his hand like
it's not my thing but get them you know
what I'm saying like get him he could
have went way harder but he didn't which
is pretty cool yeah my thing was there
get him you're the one guy to do it like
these other you know Outlets doing it
whatever
Luke does because he's an actual
journalist right he doesn't uh work like
that Luke's you know good luck
compromising Luke Thomas man he's a
Savage he's doing the best to do it
so what because he was journalist and
because it's the right thing to do he'll
bring some light to it but with the
aerial it's like get him dude you know
what I'm saying like that's where I'm at
with it's like you know Dana [ __ ] on
him and made fun of him and you know
made his life miserable for how many
years and they have this Royal I think
the worst [ __ ] up we've seen in so
long hey
get him I don't want to be part of it
I'm not gonna dog pile on it and just
talk about Dana week after week
but uh because it's not I have no
control over it I have no control I you
know I don't have nowhere near the power
Dana has I
it just doesn't make sense when we keep
you know alluding to it and commenting
on it and stuff like that but yeah get
them
[ __ ] get them dude if he's gonna
treat you like that you know it's not
even anger thing it's just like all
right you want to treat me like that now
now it's my turn
I know you have a reason to it I just
don't I don't if you're a female fighter
in the UFC
the males would get to but if you're a
female fighting you'll see you got you
gotta feel a certain way yeah and
they're scared to speak out and I I've
had a few and me and Shmo Thomas that's
a few shots we was like we wish we could
say something but it would affect our
career how insane is that
when you're employed the boss of your
company
beats up his wife on video
and you can't say anything because
you're worried it's going to affect your
career
it's 2023 in America and we're just all
okay with it
I think the other thing that scared to
me is how toxic some of the MMA fan base
is I don't think there's a more toxic
fan base in the world
it's you know the newest sport started
on the internet so obviously you can get
internet trolls but just so so toxic The
Narrative of she hit him first is insane
to me
I was like oh wow that's actually uh the
the the troll like toxic defense is she
hit him first I'm like holy [ __ ] and
people are yeah you right man like whoa
this is not I'm out
oh
just shows you a type of animal you're
dealing with man it's to me it's
eye-opening I knew how bad it was it's
eye-opening but it's also just
scary it's not powerful that to this
Mafia [ __ ] dude yeah
it's scary seems like it
scary as far as the the hitting first
two I'm like
I feel like
she's not cool either to hit him but he
cannot hit her
across the board is never okay yeah
right but so she messed up but he
shouldn't not have hit her at all no I
mean just walk away yeah that'd be like
being okay if I push my son down and
kicked him and and slapped in the face
that's the difference between me and my
son and Dana and his wife and also
remember Dana he's not what is he 50
something years old he's not like a
weathered old 50 year old he's on chat
what whatever the liver King's on yeah
Dana's on the same [ __ ] hate to tell you
he's not named steroid go
you think Connor's gonna melt a cup if
he pisses in it you know what that cup
would grow seven times the size
you know it's not so it's like
for him to hit his wife it's just it's
just it's mind-blowing to me it's
mind-blowing in public like you said
that's the most mind-blowing part that
means who knows what the [ __ ] goes on
shows you how Untouchable he feels yeah
somebody else would be like oh even if
you did it in private somebody else who
would realize that they couldn't get
away with anything would be like oh
there's no way not here when we get back
to the hotel girl
in public and this be like at okay hey
TMZ let me go and what
scary dude
I just I don't know how you vouch for
the guy now I can distinguish between
bad dude outside the octagon and great
promoter
I yeah I I don't think UFC is nowhere
near where they would be if Dana White
was in the face of it I think he's doing
great things and I've always said that
he's been the guy to carry the torch and
brought the UFC to you know remarkable
places and I don't think it gets done
without his skills and talent
doesn't mean I want to hang out with the
guy she was hell don't be married to him
you know
so I can distinguish between the two
also what do you guys think
what's going on he's a fight promoter
he's a fight promoter you know Don King
killed a guy
thank you facts dunking curb stomped and
killed a guy and did like six years in
prison
can you believe he stole money from Mike
Tyson yeah he killed a guy the promoters
that you know they they they're they're
in the fight business dude you're
dealing with some shady freaking
characters dude
of course they do this [ __ ] you know
it's just what it is
I was I when I saw the Dana video I
wasn't shocked that he hits his wife I
was shocked that he didn't public what's
that tell you
sorry
it's scary
what are you gonna do
um
what do you think they do Jen I think
he's in the clear
it's so far guys I'm talking about
things I think if the if the Uproar
didn't come within the first four days
the way the new Cycle Works you're kind
of in the clear
and I also this is what kind of hurts my
feelings as this shows you that the UC
is not as big as we thought
if this was NFL NBA MLB and they were
gonna eat let's say they wanted to
protect the guy say it was
see it was Mark Cuban or like the LeBron
James like a real big faith in NBA even
if the NBA and every player support them
the amount of pressure the public would
put on them and the advertisers it would
not matter they would have to get rid of
them with the UFC it's like have you
heard anything from any of the
advertisers look at the biggest
advertisers have you heard anything has
anyone said anything
ESPN nothing
it just shows you like there's not it
shows you how toxic the MMA fan base is
that there's not this big uprise that
there's not like how can you do this how
can nothing
because with companies now the way
corporations work in advertisers they
based off social media the new cycle
based off social media whatever's
trending they're going to do stories on
it because they know it's gonna get
clicks so if they're they're going oh
let's see how this goes like there's
actually not that much stuff going on
all right
and it just to me it's like oh the UC is
nowhere near as big as we thought
nowhere near in any other facet like if
this happened in you know uh the X Games
like Motocross or like skateboarding
you know [ __ ] it's just not that big
you'll see it's not that big
soccer biggest sport in the world this
dude kicked his wife in the leg when he
was 18 it makes the news
no evidence nothing she said he said
we have video from two weeks ago of this
dude beating the [ __ ] out of his wife
and all the advertisers like let's see
what happens nothing
and the craziest thing it's the current
event as well but the whole slap Fight
League that they're been promoting for
the last what month or two a lot right
the fact that it was supposed to come
out last week
basically or no not this was supposed to
come out this Wednesday
the fact that people thought oh for sure
they're going to put a kibosh to that
it's not going to happen anymore they
just postponed it how crazy that it's
like Rachel this is TB I know which is
so insane it's
I'm impressed it's like hold on hold on
hold on we have video of domestic
violence against your wife you're
slapping you have a league a slap fight
professional league and it just gets
postponed a week
TBS mainstream cable TV
yeah it's crazy huh it is insane
here's a question let's say I don't know
the uprise did come eventually and and
the people get a hold of it because
remember Dana's pretty Dana's boys with
Trump super boys of Trump trump
supporter uh refuse vaccines lockdowns
he's he's that far right guy he's a far
right guy right
I can't believe the left hasn't got a
hold of this
I just went bananas on it
that
how powerful he is even life is like um
but you're gonna [ __ ] with Elon Musk and
Trump and Trump like all these powerful
people but Dana where you draw the line
holy [ __ ] I might go missing after this
podcast
isn't that nuts it's insane yeah nuts
cool
never seen something like this before
and then even a [ __ ] uh Jamie Foxx
and D.L Hughley did you see their tweet
no yes DL Hughley said if it was Antonio
Brown or someone else would this be lost
in the news cycle
well a lot of people are see I don't
think it's a black white thing but I do
see how can people are saying oh look
super successful Uber successful Alpha
white male gets caught being his wife
nothing happens if Antonio Brown or
insert any black man did this it's you
know they get they get annihilated I get
it there but I think even if Dana was
black in this situation as powerful as
he is nothing would happen so DL huge
put if Chris Brown Bobby Brown or
Antonio Brown did what Dana White did
the media wouldn't stop talking about
what can Brown do for you be white
I mean he's a comedian too he's a
comedian too so he's like yeah it can
mean some of the smartest people have
the best steaks in the world though that
he's those are facts those are facts
yeah
and then preach he said [ __ ] preach
interesting
but I mean it's true it you did get lost
in the news cycle such a powerful dude I
even lost not even lost wasn't me it'd
be one thing if ESPN Fox Stephen A Smith
all them brought brought it to light
were like we cannot stand for this there
has to be some sort of discipline taken
with Dana White I know he's a friend but
there's you should never be accepted to
hit your wife then I'd be like oh man I
got lost no there's no lost it just
wasn't not covered yeah
loss you'd have to find it first
that's what that's what's even more
crazy
slap fight uh what camera uh if that had
been brother had been non-stop coverage
dredging up a playground fight from
third grade scoundrel tweets you name it
do you know what its entire life is
immersed in brutal physical violence he
amassed a fortune from it where are the
salacious headlines where's the pressure
oh he apologize hashtag white privilege
Score first round knockout yet again
yeah he has points but yeah so I'm with
you it's like it's not only the black
and white thing it's just it's just so
much power yeah how much yeah exactly
how much connections yeah successful
stuff yeah
it's fascinating I mean I I I can't
remember last time mma's had so many
black guys can't be helping the sport
right now and you know the trend's not
going upward right now
between that Phil Brony [ __ ] yep you
know Phil brownish stuff you have
anjali's sister passed away dude that's
such a [ __ ] heartbreaking man
heartbreak
it's just a lot going on right now
and you guys still want to be mean to
each other
not
what do you got Jen
let's take a little break kids Tampa I
will see you next Friday Saturday Tampa
Improv your boy is in Florida I'm going
to visit my friend Tom Brady Tampa
Florida January 20th and 21st and then
Springfield Missouri is February 3rd
through the 4th Naples February 16th
through the 18th and one night only in
Bakersfield California February 23rd
this episode the shop show is also
brought to you by audit all right
they're going to help you get that New
Year's resolution cracking with on its
New Year all you a hub for everything
you need to start the year right
throughout January get 20 off select
supplements and nutrition 10 off select
Fitness 50 off digital items like
streaming Fitness they have it all that
means Alpha Brain the number one
nootropic on the planet to support your
focus they got you man total human to
help you healthy workouts transform your
body and so much more for training you
can do at home you don't have to go to
the gym anymore join the New Year all
you on at 6 Channel college or six week
workout and lifestyle program with over
36 buckaroos and prize money up for
grabs the challenge helps you connect
with others in the audit community so
you can support each other achieve your
goals you'll be part of a team it's fun
try it out for more information don't
unlock your savings go to audit.com all
right that's on it
onnit.com
and you're getting all that saving
swimsoft select supplements and
nutrition temps off select Fitness items
50 off digital items that also means
Alpha Brain got you covered save 10 off
that as well audit.com
Last Read of the show kids we got to
keep the lights on I gotta pay this
staff I also got to keep my
hot meals for the kiddos this episode of
the shop show is also brought to you by
happy hippo the best freaking Kratom on
planet Earth Kratom you gotta trust the
company because Kratom is the wild west
you can trust my friends at happy hippo
there's a reason I reach out to them
because I love Kratom chin swears by
Kratom and I can't get enough of happy
hit Bo I use the Kratom Energy Shot I
use the Kratom extract shot it's kind of
a highly concentrated kratom in uh
liquid form one little shot and your boy
is dropping knowledge like freaking Jeff
Bezos dude I love this stuff if you want
to try it out you go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick boy
you save 20 off everything on the site
it's my Limitless pill I swear by it
there's a lot of kratoms out there but
you can trust my friends at happy hippo
all right and you get free shipping if
you get to a certain amount of money I
think you get free two-day shipping if
it's under a hundred dollars you get
free next day shipping if it's over 200
but you save 20 for Life by using the
code thick boy all right so that's Happy
Hippo
.com promo codes thick boy for 20 off
for the best Kratom to ever exist happy
hippo you're welcome now let's get back
to the program all right so over the
weekend Javonte Davis he actually got to
be able to fight he had some issues
earlier on domestic violence his thing's
interesting because did you look into it
so he posts about it wasn't that much
details his girl like took actual human
feces and put his toothbrush and all
this other [ __ ] on it and then she was
never hit she just called the cops and
said according to him like it was all
fake which by the way sometimes people
hate when I say this but sometimes girls
will do that stuff I'm not saying she
did for a fact but I'm saying that is an
option that's that that's yeah
especially when it comes to him it's a
story of like a yeah a messy track
record so you when you hear it like oh
come on how can you do this he's like
hold up you know so he goes in there
Hector uh Garcia's no punk I think he's
25-0 23 Knockouts like tough [ __ ]
character landed some shots on Javonte
Davis with Javonte he just find him you
know because uh Lewis gets hit and you
can't play that game with Javonte Davis
here's my thing with this too is you you
saw the narrative on social media like
fight was stopped early can't believe
you didn't answer the Bell
have you learned nothing after what we
see with Hamlin uh deal with after you
see with uh Stefan Bonner who I think
suffered from CT and obviously uh a drug
addiction these guys you know with
Hamlin damn near pass away on the field
from from Sports
it was his Corner not right throwing the
towel
can you live to find another when is
that not going to be a uh uh not a manly
move when is that going to be the smart
choice he clearly like he goes back out
there he's getting lit up there he said
he couldn't even see in one eye too so
I just went into society like after
seeing what happened with Hamlin there's
all this support there and then with
Bonner it's like oh my God I can't
believe he lost him and then this dude
he's getting lit up by the most powerful
puncher not named Deontay Wilder and
everyone's like man what the hell like
what I'm good with it dude what are you
guys gonna [ __ ] learn
What's it gonna take yeah I don't get it
it's a sport it's not a fight to the
death it's a sport and then uh juventy
Dave's called out Ryan Garcia there so
they're scheduled to fight uh in April
April yeah so let's see what happens
that's a fight yeah tough fight for Ryan
all right the biggest I think this is
probably the biggest news over the last
couple weeks Jake Paul Dana's bigger but
yes it's big that's true so yeah but
well it depends what news Outlet you are
there's yeah
people are actually covering this one
so Jake Paul signing with pfl to do
actual MMA like a multi-fight multi-year
multi-fight deal MMA unboxing I think
yeah I'm not surprised by this it's
smart by Jake think dude think about
Jake
when all this stuff went down you know
Jake Paul and his brother Logan Paul the
first to kind of crossover from those
YouTuber influencers into the boxing
World it started with Logan Paul and KSI
but KSI called out Logan Paul and Jake
Paul in a video right and Jake back then
wanted MMA
she said that was his first Passion yeah
he's a wrestling background yeah he's
done more wrestling he has boxing so if
you want to do it back then he's
fighting for Fighters pay you know he
says the the fighters will get 50 of the
revenue which is unheard of I don't know
if that's a business model that you can
sustain but God willing hopefully get it
done
um I think what Jake is doing we haven't
seen this is uh I don't think we've ever
seen a guy go from being so hated to so
beloved like even at my fans like Jesus
Christ okay this is cool you know I
think it's funny two people like you
think he's really gonna fight MMA Jake's
different than these other guys who are
flaky name one thing Jake has said that
he hasn't actually shown up for and done
of course he didn't do mm if he would
sign with pfl just to what [ __ ] foot
around and just do boxing no
super ballsy man he's so ballsy with MMA
I'm curious what he's gonna do
I think what I would do if I was him is
get the Nate Diaz fight box Nate first
and beat him and then mma's gonna be
tough for him against Nate deals so then
if you can beat Nate in boxing then you
beat him in MMA that trilogy fight you
make a [ __ ] ton of money off of both of
you and he can decide box on MMA
mm-hmm
it's gonna be interesting
but you can't toss them like a legit
Bellator guy you know or uh pfl guy
yeah they'll make a big move
that's a huge move dude Jake Paul uh so
this is Sean O'Malley giving his take on
this whole thing when you're talking
about him fighting some guys they're
just Strikers Sean O'Malley says that he
should probably not even even
concentrate on Jiu Jitsu just focus on
the takedown defense yeah yeah here's my
other thing though
these UFC guys are defending Dana hey
hey stop stop stop hey you know you're
not gonna get like a bonus because you
did that right you know there's no
upside to that like does some party
coming out being like I don't agree with
it a man should never hit a woman that's
what a stand-up Champion does dude
that's what you do
for all these Fighters being like well
she did him first like hey hey stop you
know Dana's not going to come to the
rescue and give you a 50 000 bonus
because you stuck up for him I've never
understood that
this co-signing of Dana White when he
does something terrible or something you
don't agree with that you shouldn't
agree with because you're you want to be
a company man you giant [ __ ] what are
you doing
there's no way to vouch for this the
fighters are doing it hey dumbass you
know this doesn't mean you're getting an
extra six fight contract because you
co-signed your boss hitting a woman
it's insane to me dude and there's the
news on there like sugar Shawn sticks up
for Dana he was joking so I saw him like
oh hell no
yeah that was his uh but I feel bad for
Dan his wife slapped him that's rude and
deserves slapped him back I don't know I
don't know It's Tricky when I don't know
treat people how you want to be treated
but he went on to say like he would
never hit he never hit his own girl he
said it wasn't joking it's tough man I I
just I don't understand how these guys
are co-signing this
sober would he have ever done that no
really Sean how would he know him that's
true you ever hung out of his house
you don't hit a woman in public for the
first time ever in your life I don't
give a [ __ ] how drunk you are
have you ever been hit by a girl in
public
um never in public in private I've been
hit
okay that's funny but I remember being
in like a brawl and then this girl
this girl just straight up smacked me
and I just of course I can't do [ __ ]
with her no so I just saw her friend I
started going off with her yeah yeah
you can't do it yeah
anyways that's one of the takes on this
Sean O'Malley and then um
oh let's go back to the Jake Paul stuff
so
uh Ben asgren I guess he still has you
know a contract with UFC but he's open
to doing the pfl match with uh Jake Paul
which I think would be pretty
interesting right no no I mean that'd be
a nightmare for Jake you're one of the
best you've ever seen just Molly [ __ ]
shoe also if you're Jake Paul's team
you're sitting around let's say about
today you're sitting around with your
marketing team who are clearly Geniuses
and nobody does a better promo in
fighting you're sitting around and they
go what about the Ben Askin fight if I
was probably with my handgirl pros and
cons
foreign
we kind of put up a fight but we're
probably gonna lose right and we
starched them
you know we start them we can't get
better than that so there's only
downside to this fight with him against
Ben Benny just a wrestler
you know he's the wrestler the worst
matchup for impossible give him another
Striker
don't give him a guy who can just
doesn't strike who just wants to grab us
the nightmare for Jake
there's no upside to it I love Ben I
hope he gets a fight and gets paid but
he would absolutely Molly [ __ ] him MMA
the wrestling is insane people I it's a
shame and again that's our sport people
realize how good Ben asking was that
[ __ ] mixed martial arts Bonafide Hall
of Famer one chip what was he a one
Championship uh world champion Bellator
Bellator world champion he was like 20
and something to know comes UFC with a
bad hip and he's over the hill and
people like oh Ben wasn't that good it's
like oh my God
you guys have no clue what you're
talking about he destroyed Douglas Lima
who everyone thinks is one of the best
in the world and Andre uh kreshkov yes
who's a [ __ ] crazy badass so yeah
and how do you think Jake would do
against Douglas Lehman uh crisscross
yeah it's not well exactly right so it's
a
there's no upside from the the those
like fighting Woodly in MMA are you know
um fight National and silver and MMA
that you've already beat them in boxing
go and put that feather in your cap
let's get something new we need
something new out of it
there's no upside uh Pettis did say uh
he would want to fight Jake Paul Striker
mostly right so
Striker
as we know Pettis is [ __ ] Damian Maya
on the ground compared to Jake Paul I've
rolled with Paris Pettis is a Savage on
the ground it would be a nightmare for
him what if it was pure boxing in PFO
pure boxing Anthony Pettis and uh Jake
Paul cat Anthony pass is so undersized
that's a Savage though but Palestine pfl
hasn't you know yeah hasn't been if I'm
past I don't know why you do that yeah
the only if I'm Paris I only take that
fight if grappling and jujitsu's
involved Pettis
would submit him
um going back to this real quick so we
literally just talked about Victoria Lee
like in what like two shows ago how
badass our family is yeah remember
Anjali was on food truck and she was
talking about her sister yeah and she
was saying how she's like she's more
Talent than me she has Charisma you need
to have her on food truck she loves to
talk she's really good at it she's like
she's gonna break every record there is
it is so tragic I can't fathom what that
family is dealing with
you know apparently it happened uh
December 26 was like a day after
Christmas and they just uh announced it
recently gorgeous girl too gorgeous
talented had all the all they had the
World by the freaking nuts man horrible
horrible horrible horrible
yeah 2023 coming in hot dude [ __ ]
it's nuts right now and even before that
dude Rumble Johnson he lost theodoro
Stefan Bonner like what the [ __ ]
horrible
all right uh so we kind of talked about
this already but uh so khabib is saying
that he's gonna oh not khabib people are
saying around him that he's not going to
be coaching anymore not doing anything
with MMA in 2023 because because he
wants to focus his time with his family
because he's not been there for
you he's been doing a lot of coaching
for the long Travelers everywhere yeah
yeah let's focused on his family yep and
he said he's gonna leave it forever
apparently here's the thing about khabib
too remember they're like oh I bet he
comes back and fights or oh I better
come back some coaches no no it's just a
man of his work dude yeah I mean I don't
there's no evidence to show that once he
says something he doesn't just stick by
it man this dude does not play yeah he
doesn't do it for clicks don't give a
[ __ ] about your likes retweets you know
read repost he he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's he's good but you were saying that
he was saying also that
um mma's on the kind of decline yeah he
said in his opinion it is on the decline
yeah yeah I think there's I think that
factor into it I think the time away
from his family factored into it also
being retired and then also I would be
willing to bet he does not Vibe with
what Dana did
whoa I bet he's like I'm out that's an
interesting yeah but he's like I'm out
no comment I'm [ __ ] done with it
um
and then also remembers Eagle FC was
paying guys in like crypto
remember that whole crypto thing yeah um
some people wanted crypto so yeah
come here
I think there's all those factors into
it Dana stuff he's like all right I'm
I'm out man
so there could be a possible tie to that
we talked about this already uh but so
Phil Browning he's being moved to a
place that's considered like a notorious
prison for a hardcore you know Mexican
cartel yeah yes so cerezo prison he's
facing up to 30 to 50 years for murder
and I guess his trial or his judge he's
gonna be the judge today on a Monday
yeah and there's no trial the evidence
is so he's like no you're 50 years and
they found I saw this picture here of
his hands
and you can obviously it's there's
redness on the right hand yeah
I mean even in that cartel prison uh I
think Phil's gonna be okay as far as
fighting them yeah yeah but they really
don't fight Dylan they gang up on them
yes I don't know but I'm saying so
according to the police like Phil said
that he just not just just that's [ __ ]
up he pushed her and she fell down and
hit her head or whatever but then the
police are saying like she had all the
you said they said contusions it doesn't
add up yeah and his hands are all you
know he's screwed
you gotta be manslaughter yeah yeah yeah
they're not gonna so they're gonna find
out today I guess if it's gonna be these
[ __ ] the other thing too for those out
there that are using the defense with
Dana that she hit him first okay so
using the same defense with Phil what if
she hit him first
nope is that cool like where do you guys
draw the line
let's say his girlfriend hit him first
after stormshita is that cool just leave
him first guys how stupid of an argument
is that
I know
all right so this video came out of Ilia
to peria who just beat Bryce Mitchell
uh and this is kind of a it's a little
weird because so Ilia to peria is with
this really famous uh famous Spanish
singer and then some of the artists they
thought he was actually fighting the
Spanish singer but they're homies oh
right so I'll just play this video for
you I'm not sure if I'm gonna play this
but I'll play it for you yeah you play
it for me not on the video so where's uh
this is uh this is Spain somewhere he's
playing the game the white shirt
someone's pushing him
and then he just goes to town on him
right
like I was kind of asking for it pushing
yeah but it's kind of like this is a
random video out of nowhere so I looked
it up more
and I guess that guy that uh his Spanish
singer friend he made this other video
before where he was in a fight to
promote one of his music videos
so it seems like this could possibly be
some sort of like thing oh he's tied to
this because the Spanish singers with
him somewhere in this uh in this video
so he was like a marketing potentially I
don't know but it's hard to find any
details about this stuff but that's the
Spanish singer his name is Omar Montes
huh
shut the Omar
he has 1.4 mil followers and you can see
right here he's homies he posted a video
of Ilia
yeah the prayers are straight badass he
is
um quick one Dylan Dennis you know he
pulled out of his fight with KSI he's
supposed to be on food truck this week
really is he or not uh uh I think we
postponed it okay so we I know we have
somebody else this week but I know we
postponed it
okay so apparently um ksi's manager said
that he pulled out because he was
unprepared for the match and then Dylan
Dana said something like it's fake news
and he's gonna like tell the truth
eventually it's gonna shock everyone
because as to why he had to pull out you
know
I think he actually text me this morning
let me see yeah I mean I you know I
don't know you know who knows what the
hell's going on yeah
dude I don't think you realize how big
KSI is
in Europe I think right yeah okay so in
uh in yeah in UK in Europe he's he's
I mean just the way he trans the numbers
he's bigger than like Logan Paul and
um Jake Paul like he's massive yeah I
had no idea he sold out though to Arena
easily and I saw him I saw the boxing
match he's not he's not bad no no he
actually beat Logan Paul
and Logan Paul actually lasted with
Floyd Mayweather as whatever sure but
whatever that is yeah but still
interesting yeah what else you got a
quick one just a fight announcement this
is uh Casey O'Neill who's killing it
right now
she's gonna fight she's a beast Jennifer
Maya good fight Eliminator yeah I dig
that
and so there's rumors about we heard
this like a few weeks already right that
Umar usman's hands like yeah people sent
me pictures so
um Ali abdelaziz is saying that uh
enough of the rumors Kamara is fighting
Leon next he's good to go and it'll be
March though right and London is fairly
as much I think it's more in London so I
don't know if you have a cast on I don't
know here's the thing about tomorrow
though like he's had bad knees forever
and still figures it out so I wouldn't
be surprised if he gets it done another
rumor was if Kamara can't fight then
Smiles at all which I would watch is
history there yeah Mazda doll that'd be
great by the way there's some guys that
they just they have a different set of
rules where people like they haven't won
a fight and I don't care
there's like the Nate Diaz Nick Diaz is
the Donald cerrone's the Mazda dolls
those old heads the Robbie LawLers those
old heads Matt Browns where when they
get these big fights they put them like
main event of comment and I'm like man
they found it for sure
yeah but they're jumping the queue yeah
yeah they've earned it yep I don't care
with that stuff and they're always
exciting oh and there's a like there's
more of a history of uh miles Vidal
there's a deeper weird like kind of
[Music]
um
antagonistic history between mazatol and
Leon Edwards with Camaro Usman I mean
granted that head kick one of the
greatest knockouts ever and then Kamal
beat him before years ago what five six
years before that uh via wrestling so
they're one-on-one either way it's a
good story but I have no issue with Leon
Edwards in hospital I if I were to pick
the fight I would prefer Mazda doll Leon
me too I'd pay for I would because I
don't think Leon uh Camaro is a great
fight yeah I mean Corral is just
dominating dominating crazy and they
made a mistake and that's why we love
the sport but yep the chance of that
happening back to back
but you don't know like no I I know I
like to make predictions right but you
don't know you can't say that I know but
okay okay dude well then there won't be
a show if I just didn't you know
yeah but I mean I don't know as a fan
Leon Mosby know I just I love that
storyline it'd be awesome yeah so
entertaining yeah I love mosinol oh yeah
so this is uh I saw this interview with
a Brett okamoto and Bryce Mitchell and
Hussein is retiring right no no he's
he's saying like um
when you're weight cutting you're
essentially dying right you're basically
stripping your body of nutrients yeah so
he thinks which I don't think is ever
going to happen but he thinks to be
completely Fair
people should weigh in right before you
fight like literally minutes before you
fight you know when people are putting
the the Vaseline on your face and
whatever way in because that's that's
your true weight you're not rehydrating
you're not doing anything else it's a
true rate yeah and you guys should be
paid more what else you want
that's it's never happening I know I
know so what did he say about the loss I
know he said he had the flu or something
flu which he said he said Pay did factor
into it yes so he she apparently only
had two thousand dollars in the bank
account in December and he had that
would last until February right so he's
like I had to take the fight he but he
also he says he doesn't blame the UFC
for how much money he's getting you know
how much money he's making he's making
good money but he invests his money on
his farm and equipment and all that
stuff so but
that was a a factor right what seven in
the world at the time before he left
probably yeah he was he was the top so
you guys know number number seven 145 on
the planet has
two thousand dollars in this bank
account again this goes back to I don't
think UFC is as big as we think name
another athlete who's the seventh best
in any position in the NBA
soccer NFL MLB you're the seventh best
in the world and you have two thousand
dollars in your account
go so to be so he did say that he did
buy a lot of stuff to you know invest in
the farm and all that stuff so maybe
that but either way he should still have
a lot of money but a hundred thousand
dollars into the farm you should still
have the seventh best 145er in the world
you shouldn't have to the biggest
organization and you can't buy some some
hay for your horses
laughs
oh gosh
so anyways Sean O'Malley heard the
interview I guess
oh well but remember he he trolled uh
sugar yeah these young kids are savages
and then this is what Shawn O'Malley
said after the interview [ __ ] these
guys man these young kids scroll up let
me read what Bryce said so honestly I
had a couple thousand bucks in my bank
account they told me if you don't take
this fight we're not finding you one
until February we're booked so it's like
you can live off a couple thousand bucks
in your bank or you can fight December
10th if not [ __ ] off until February so I
said you know what I don't want to live
off a couple thousand bucks till
February I would have made it I could
have scraped by and maybe I should have
but at the time I thought I'd win the
fight I thought I was going to go in
there uh with the flu to kick somebody's
ass anyway and that just wasn't the case
I was not capable of kicking ass that
night and then shook up a damn B hit me
up I could have spotted you 20. see you
soon next time these Savages I know
yeah fight with the flu is a bad idea
especially at this level it takes
everything even even at full capacity
that's a tough fight dude
yeah anyone who's had the flu knows it's
devastating anywhere you mean everybody
Chad I know anyone but when everybody
knows can relate what when you're
actually going through the flu Oh no you
can't even if you you brought it up yeah
you feel weak yeah imagine doing three
five minute rounds against Emporia yeah
yeah it didn't go well
um
so
Jose Aldo
he's going to be boxing in a pro debut
on February 10th so the only thing he's
doing he's gonna have to you see the
recent yeah I have it for fighting the
kid but we'll we'll talk about yeah
there's recent allegations that his wife
was taking money right oh wait I didn't
see that part
no I didn't say that part oh what'd you
have for finding the kid uh Brazil the
president yeah who's a far-right guy was
staying at his house he's no longer the
president there right yeah so so it's
just like the January 6th thing with the
Trump stuff so the people were against
him not being reelected so they started
you know upright going crazy yeah yeah
Brazil's having problems right now and
then he let him stay at his house yep in
Florida and then his wife was saying
that the left the extreme leftist came
after him like making up these headlines
saying she was stealing money I was like
when I read the headline Jesus Christ
you look into it she's still like
well if it's true like 200 bucks
you know but stole this is a story well
they said it was like for covid-19
relief program or whatever it was PPO
you know things
I don't know it sounds like some
[ __ ] I didn't hear that stuff
all right this is
someone sent this in I don't know what
it is but I'll just show you a quick
clip you know how we've been seeing a
lot of stuff that goes on in Russia like
before the fight they just start
fighting yep so this is one of the
videos I don't know if we can play it
but we'll see
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hold my senior frog Margarita check this
out
it get goose huh uh this is also a post
this is Terence McKinney posting it but
let's see here I'm about to revoke uh
dick Lewis's credentials to the thick
boy club he keeps losing weight so it
looks like he's super lean and he's
worth thinking yeah yeah well he's in uh
he's at the crossroads of his career
right he's lost a few you know Cardiff
could be an issue
that could just be a really good angle
sometimes people take pictures of him
like God damn am I Jared Leto but then
in real life like oh you're still big
and this picture is also kind of like a
little not the best resolution oh yeah I
don't know yeah but I'm sure he's good
yeah uh let's go so this is just Legion
Liang calling out opponents
and he goes
but hey Tony I'm bored now it's too hot
in Florida let's party me and you have
unfinished business let's dance and
March same party and dance uh are you
ready let's go champ I don't even know
if he's actually writing this stuff and
then he calls out all these people here
hey all you are also invited to the
party if you want to come let's dance
that'd be fun uh Moreno that'd be fun
Los Angeles Tony Ferguson in March I can
make barbecue for y'all I don't think
he's um tweeting that yeah I don't think
he could speak also why does he have
jeans on in a rash guard
now Barbecue's [ __ ] lit though look
at that thing that does look dope oh
chin I went to this um
coffee place in Vegas and they based it
off uh 1940 Japan it was so dope a
coffee place based off of 1940 Japan
yeah it was so sick
so dope I was chilled there every day me
and my brother's children and the coffee
was nice every that nice food
everything's nice
all right so this was kind of making the
rounds here this Hamza posting
a picture of himself any of these just
looks super jacked
I was getting ready for a bit of weight
or maybe he's getting ready to fight uh
Alex Pierre because of our bed at uh
late heavyweight
yeah potentially just [ __ ] fight that
guy nobody wants to fight him he's
terrifying look at him
yeah he does look super black and white
also makes you like shows like the
striats and your muscle and stuff like
that but still he's jacked either way
yeah that beard scares [ __ ] too I don't
know who the [ __ ] gonna beat him
all right uh just a couple more your boy
Satoshi ishi it just popped up it just
popped up recently he's jack [ __ ] yeah
and I guess he's boxing now
really yeah he's never been known to be
a boxer no
for you those of you he's looking wow he
looks fantastic yeah
well if he's still the same girl and I
was trained with him he had this just
straight white girl with red head red
hair white girl
does she speak Japanese no sir it was
hilarious it was fantastic
he's such a good dude
let's try his team pro cup
so see uh last I had another boxing
match it was a majority draw
another step in my career which is going
to help me grow as a fighter
weird when your background's uh Judo I
know you're on the boxing he was never
known for a striking ever yeah but he's
uh his left Hooks and right hooks were
nightmares but he was you know nervous
thing
speaking of fighting how about our Boy
George as you went to the yes bring that
up how about you went to the fights at
the college City Casino our Boy George
so
um uh keto George you guys know him from
King The Sting I saw the weight there he
is there with his stomach melting he uh
hey man what stop melting but okay I
know what you're saying okay that's a
positive thing don't put him next to
issue right now I know Jesus Christ this
is on there what are you doing
but um yeah keto George lost his fight
via submission to a guillotine and then
tall George beat the [ __ ] out of his guy
so okay I was there and keto George I
I'll tell you though I've never seen him
look the way he he was just like
determined even though he was walking by
I was like hey George because I was
luckily in a row where they walked by
next to me yeah he was just like gave me
a wink it's all business and dude he was
so legit like a real fighter yeah I'm so
proud I talked to him afterwards because
unfortunately I couldn't be there sorry
with Alton Rich child but I couldn't be
that I wanted to I sent them videos and
just talked to him a little bit the day
of the fight
but I told Jordan before they went I
said listen I don't care if you guys win
or lose you get knocked out in three
seconds what you're doing 99.9 so balls
has never done or never will even
attempt to do so you guys even getting
in there you've won man yeah like this
isn't about win or lose or how you guys
look it's just about going through the
process and experiencing it like you're
gonna be better for this
but George tall George yeah did work we
knew he was gonna We he's he comes from
such an athletic back our family yeah
his brother plays for my shitty Broncos
but he's uh he's a highlight of the year
yeah George is doing uh yeah
and I met Rich Chow such a cool dude man
dude great all right she's my guy
we'll post something for the boys though
and then I set uh George cash out with
some some moolah I said I need you and
George to go out tonight have a nice
dinner and some drinks man that's
beautiful that's awesome yeah I'm proud
of those boys yeah
I mean now tall Jordan's just a crow cop
outfit yeah Croatian says which is
offensive but that's fine that's
gracious yeah
that was dope when we first brought him
for an interview he's like yeah first
time I saw is when you were fighting
Crow cop man I was like oh yeah he's
like yeah yeah I hated it [ __ ] up
but yeah shout out to those guys is that
it that's it man you have a fight night
at the Apex Center uh 4 P.M Vegas
Saturday you have Kevin gaslum and uh um
uh Danny Danny Iggy's fighting uh Damon
Jackson's a fun coming event uh Viera
penton's a good one
Umar [ __ ] madoff's fighting uh raw
socks fighting yeah the card's not gonna
blow your [ __ ] hair back
you think Dana shows up I'll answer that
no
you know what's crazy about Dana though
so you know he does the [ __ ] it Friday
video I don't know if you know that so
uh they definitely take that from me
marketing remember I remember when he
was just firing people and he was like
cutting guys I was like yo Dana woke up
was like [ __ ] it [ __ ] it Wednesday
some of his marketing and all that
Friday was okay marketing let's call it
[ __ ] Fridays and he's like that's a
brilliant idea yeah so he I thought for
sure he wouldn't do it after this whole
you know controversy but he once again
did it I have to have to go back to work
if you're him you got to stay the path
yeah like if you go quiet you know it's
a little weird which I agree with yeah
don't go quiet no because if he you know
he issues apology into him like that's
good enough in his head you got you
can't go missing M.I.A missed the fights
like the big pay-per-view in January he
has to show up at like business as usual
yep like well what can you do
I don't know I'm gonna I'll have his
wife at the fighting chick
her out she's there she's cool she's hip
she's cool you know yeah that's all
marketing
is that it brother that's it all right
kids uh next time I'm on the road Tampa
Tampa's next week next Friday and
Saturday only so that is
um January 20th 21st I'm in Tampa Bay
Tampa Bay Florida so bring your uh old
school rookie year Steve Young jerseys
Mike alstott one of my favorite places
to ever do it get out that Tom Brady
dust off them Tom Brady jerseys and get
your ass to the Tampa Improv only Friday
and Saturday and then Springfield
Missouri Springfield January I'm sorry
February 3rd through the 4th Naples
Florida is February 16th to the 18th
Bakersfield California February 23rd one
show only Brea California right now I'm
just promoting March 4th so there's one
night only in Brea California March 4th
get your tickets right now at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com thickboy.com you can get
all your merch we have a sale going
right now we have a new drop coming as
well we have new tour merch can only get
in person I'll blast that out on my
social media for you guys so you can see
it you get that in person
if you want that award-winning sweet
thick nectar uh we're on batch number
three baby get you some right now get
delivered to your crib at thickboy.com
all right and we cover uh I think we
take five dollars off shipping get you
some all right kids love you be safe out
there 2023 is coming in hot and hard but
we can uh we can turn this thing around
hopefully all the bad news is over and
the rest of the years can be fantastic
all right love you guys be safe out
there till next time I'm out if you're
into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding